[Music]
hi I'm Todd Smith I'm going to share
with you some information that has
changed my life it's about an individual
named Dr Joel wallik he's a veterinarian
who worked with the famous Marlon
Perkins of the Mutual of Omaha Wild
Kingdom I think the thing that makes my
view different on health is that I'm a
veterinarian as well as a physician 23
years of experience as a licensed
physician dealing with people and their
diseases worked on a big uh Grant with
the National Institutes of Health and
Marlon Perkins from the old Mutual Omaha
Wild Kingdom days uh was a $7.5 million
Grant did over 20,000 autopsies 17,500
autopsies and over 454 species of
animals and 3,000 human beings for
comparison so it gives me a little
unique position in my training one of Dr
wallick's Landmark discoveries was this
the more complex the organism the more
nutrients it requires so we learned a
long time ago in the animal industry
that we could prevent and cure diseases
in animals with simple little
nutritional formulas you find these in
little alphalpha pellets we've been so
successful at using this technique over
the last 75 years we've eliminated about
900 different diseases in animals with
nutrition that still plague people so
what are the results of adding
nutritional supplements to animals feed
well let's take man's best friend for
example the dog have you ever heard of
dog years experts have said for years
that one dog year is equal to seven
human years that's because the average
dog in the 1960s lived to be 10 and the
average human was dying in their 70s you
know simple math 7 to1 today the
lifespan of dogs and cats is doubled
whereas the lifespan of humans is
unchanged and the only real difference
is that the animals are eating a perfect
diet fortified with over 40 minerals and
the humans are not and as a veterinarian
it always seemed odd to me that we would
U use this technique for animals nobody
was doing it for people and I lectured
to doctors for many years during their
continued educ ation programs wrote
scientific articles some 75 plus and um
I was never able to get doctors
interested in preventing and curing
diseases in people with nutritional
fulas and so I went back to school and
became a physician and since 1978 I've
been using these little Veterinary
nutritional formulas on my human
patients and I can tell you that the
concept of preventing and curing
diseases in animals with nutritional
formulas works the same in people have
you ever read the label of a can of
human infant formula have seen how few
minerals there are in it our dogs and
cats are getting over 40 minerals and
our babies are getting less than 12 it's
pretty frightening really I mean on that
logic you'd think dogs and cats are more
complex than humans there are over 77
minerals naturally occurring in the
human body 77 60 of them are essential
for health you know the fundamental
problem is the difference between
vitamins and minerals plants can
manufacture vitamins but they're
dependent on the soil they grow in for
their minerals plants can combine water
and nutrients from the soil through a
process called photosynthesis to produce
vitamins and amino acids minerals
however cannot be manufactured by the
plant in essence the minerals must be
present in the soil to be absorbed by
the
plant another important thing to
understand is that minerals do not occur
in a uniform blanket over the face of
the Earth they occur in veins like gold
or silver and tend to accumulate in
locations such as ancient riverbeds or
glacial runoff where the soils from
multiple times in locations have
congregated well the basic thing that
people need to know about
supplementation is that essential
nutrients are called essential nutrients
for two reasons number one our bodies
can't manufacture them must consume them
every day either as food or as
supplements secondly if we don't consume
them every day we're going to get not
maybe perhaps could we're going to get
many horrible deficiency diseases many
of which are
life-threatening the problem we face
today is that our food is no longer
grown in mineral rich areas large Farms
that have been growing crops for decades
are now depleted of these vital minerals
Farmers replace only what is necessary
to make sure their crops will grow take
a look at this study from the
USDA you can see that the drop in
Mineral and vitamin content in our food
has been significant we can see it in
corn onions broccoli strawberries and
many other fruits and
vegetables if the minerals are not in
our food we need to supplement in order
to maintain good health look at how much
we could reduce diseases if we were just
taking the minimum recommendations of
vitamins and minerals each day according
to the USDA estimate one day Dr Jo
wallof came to my office and um placed a
bottle on my desk and said these are
plant derived minerals I want you to
examine those well so we did and you
found some very very interesting results
that made me really convinced that this
is a great product not only doesn't
contain a great many elements it also
contains them in a form which makes them
substantially active the bottle that Dr
wallet gave to Dr shraer turned out to
be plant derived colloidal minerals from
an ancient plant deposit found in the
pristine mountains of Utah far away from
pollution and human contact these
ancient plants lived at a time and in a
location were more than 70 minerals
naturally occurred in the soils and were
therefore taken up in the plants that
grew there these mineral plants having
never fossilized or turned to stone have
been intuned and preserved for hundreds
of thousands of years there are many
traditional stories which have been told
about these Mountain Springs American
Indians speak of the magical healing
benefits they experience when drinking
from them early Prospectors included
stories in their journals of how these
Waters helped EAS joint pain and other
illnesses modern science and
Manufacturing have been able to better
explain the Amazing Stories stemming
from these Mountain Streams bottom line
we need to get our minerals from plants
dos Wallock and malan knew this and felt
compelled to get this message out in
fact that's why Dr wallik went back to
school and practiced privately for over
12 years treating human patients with
these animal formulas giving them the
nutrition that they needed and after
thousands and thousands of people having
positive results they felt now they need
to take this message to the masses they
need to reach more people and they
turned to the power of Word of Mouth
they formed a company American Longevity
with the purpose of changing
lives American Longevity is a
flourishing multi-million dollar company
passionate about spreading the message
of good health they've designed an
extensive line of nutritional products
based upon the science of plant- derived
minerals they' put together a team of
scientists and doctors respected around
the world that are recommending these
products to their patients for good
health all the members in our family
have found very good results using these
products we have a daughter and after
starting her on the recommended products
about 2 weeks into it she was a
different child it was just night day
all of a sudden she was sweet and kind
and loving and she took the rock out
from under her pillow that she kept
there to throw at the other kids in the
night if they made her
mad before using CM cream I I've had a
whole lot of aching joints and pain I'm
41 years of age and the thing about that
is ever since I started taking the CM
cream I've been pain
free that makes all the difference in
the world my husband introduced me to to
these products and I've been taking them
now for 2 years and I've noticed a real
difference in my health and I have a lot
more energy and overall Vitality I
outfit people on hunting trips and pack
trips into the high mountains of Utah
and wyomi in my writing it's very uh
labor intensive and uh my knees were
weing out and they were hurting my
shoulders were hurting my thumb was
hurting but my arm was hurting my back
was hurting well I got on this on
February the 7th I'd say in 3 months
time I had no more pain I had all kinds
of energy I'm 75 years old I'm doing
work of a 50-year-old man it's awesome
what American longivity has done for my
body I had just got traded to Atlanta I
had multitude of injuries um I had just
came from uh making an All-Star team but
I wasn't able to play an Allstar team
because I had broken my wrist I used the
product came back the next year and had
a a great Year stay healthy for like
three straight years without any issues
so I was working at a fast food
restaurant I was overweight I had knee
problems being overweight I couldn't
exercise I was eating all of the wrong
foods and so it caused a whole lot of
problems uh I was introduced to the
products and um I lost the weight I
changed my eating habit so I changed my
diet and I have taken care of the knee
problems and I've been able to um really
changed my whole life with the American
Longevity products American Longevity is
about educating people and we're now in
many countries um it takes a lot of
people to pass on this message as
passionate as I am about it one person
can't do this and so we've decided to
reward people financially for helping
and spread the message and it's very
exciting how many people take on the
responsibility to pass on the message
and we pay very well we like to help
people not only with their health but
also their Financial Health and
well-being and we're very very proud of
American and Jody for being able to pull
this off we actually pay out more than
any other network marketing company out
there uh in theory and in reality I I
particularly interested when uh I hear
that uh Blake is planning to uh introdu
this business to Japan I was not
successful in any other uh programs but
uh in in this levity people are more uh
willing to listen and uh my downline is
still
growing and I'm very successful it's a
huge opportunity for people that want to
build a business off of providing high
quality good products that people see
benefit and value in that's really a
very rewarding part of my job is to see
those ideas implemented into a not only
a usable product but a product that
people then see value in and then we get
testimonials back on those products from
the time they went from being just an
idea to an actual product to people
receiving benefit and Reporting back
results and so that's the the most
rewarding part for me but also for our
Distributors you know I I hear countless
stories from Distributors that love
getting those testimonials and the
feedback from their customers and and
people they know they've helped this
company was established by Distributors
again for Distributors so we have their
uh needs in mind and we know what they
go through out in the field to promote
the products and so we're very receptive
to their input and ideas because it's on
a downline system people can utilize you
know a star athlete being involved with
the product in order to sell rebound and
you know create a business off of it I
first got involved with the Australian
longevity by taking their Cal minerals
from then I started becoming a
distributor now I have um people in five
different countries Distributing for
me Australian longevity allowed me to
choose what I want to do not what I have
to do you need to get involved in
American Longevity if you want to do
something more if you want to do more
than just make money it's a way to make
a difference it's something you can sink
your teeth into the products are there
the financial support is there the
Integrity is there and to me if you
don't have integrity you have nothing
it's given me the opportunity to quit my
daytime job and be a stay-at-home mom
but not only that it gave us a Financial
Freedom to take a 2-year retirement and
go travel 48 of the states with Dan my
myself and our son Zachary and our check
has increased every month in our
retirement and I don't know anyone else
our age I can do that I needed to do
something that will Empower me for my
future and I am so glad I
did if people knew what they're
missing then they wouldn't miss it they
would do whatever they could to make
this work whatever it is as far as
health goes and as far as making extra
money a month you know it's it's not
that hard I'm tell you I live in um
Washington now Washington DC and let me
tell you people there are stressed out
High strong and about ready to break and
it just amazes me they go to work at 7
o'clock in the morning they get home at
7 or 8:00 at night they are totally
stressed out and so many people that are
like that all across the country if they
just knew what a residual income could
do they would do whatever it took to
build a residual income and at the same
time help
people truth is I'm a distributor of
American Longevity and have been for
eight years I joined the company back
when my wife and I found out we were
going to have triplets and I had to quit
my job to stay in school I was
introduced to this company because of
the products because they'd helped my
parents so much with their health they
told me they said Todd if you can find a
way to make money with this you've got
yourself an incredible business because
these products are for real and they
really work these products in this
company have for provided us some
incredible health benefits as a family
they provided us some Financial
opportunities and things that we just
never dreamed about a lifestyle that we
thoroughly enjoy I hope you've enjoyed
this information I've enjoyed sharing it
with you and I hope you'll join us with
our American Longevity
family hey
I